uh the day has just flown by
and we're ending on a real high note
here with pravesh katari
at cmu who's going to tell us about some
of squares robust statistics and i'm
sure
a bunch of other exciting things so take
it away pravesh
all right thanks adam and thanks to the
organizers for inviting me to give this
talk
so uh yeah as adam said i want to tell
you about uh
this nasa incline of work in algorithmic
robust statistics
specifically you know related to the use
of the sum of squares method
in designing algorithms for problems
that arise in this area
um this is a rather broad title so let
me maybe say a couple sentences about
what i
intend to do in this talk now in several
talks
we or at least i you know have mentioned
this phrase that hey
sum of squares gives a general blueprint
for designing algorithms for robust
statistics problems
but we never actually described that
blueprint you know except
by means of a single example relevant to
that talk today i want to fix that
i want to tell you what this blueprint
is and two
you know one has to make compromises
when they give talks to focus on some
aspects and not
not on others and one technical but
very important aspect is usually not
covered in talks
i want to make sure that that part is
stressed upon today
and as i'll argue this technical aspect
is in fact the engine that drives the
success of the sum of squares method
in this context and i'll i'll leave you
with like two open problems that relate
to this technical primitive and can
you know improve algorithms for several
problems in this area
okay with that prologue let me start
oh no ah there we are okay so let me
start by you know just telling you
the context in which you know this line
of work sets in
i'm sure you know there are so many
recorded talks these days that you're
all aware of it but
i'll just spend a minute so you know
there are several problems in machine
learning that involve learning from data
and you know the way we do them is by
choosing an appropriate
statistical model to the data and then
you know designing an algorithm for
fitting that model to you know the input
that we actually have
now you know several problems look like
this from this very simple
problems like linear regression to you
know somewhat more complicated problems
like learning gaussian mixture models
now one thing that we typically do in
both design
and analysis of such algorithms is
assume
that the input data that we are going to
see is an iid
sample from our chosen model right
now this is at best an idealized
assumption
so one must ask what happens if you know
there are some minor
perturbations or departures from this
assumption in the input that you
actually see
how resilient is your algorithm to minor
perturbations
this is not a new question this was
asked more than 60 years ago
by eminent statisticians like john tukey
and peter huber
and you know they phrased it as hey you
know what what happens if
the input data deviates from being an
iid sample does your estimator still
continue to work
and they were motivated by you know
pretty realistic real life settings
where for example there are a small
fraction of outliers in the data
or the model was like slightly
mis-specified you know the input sample
was generated from a close by but not
exactly the model you chose
and they discovered that estimators in
general actually are not
you know going to play well with such
perturbations and that led to this
really interesting and important field
of robust statistics which has lots and
lots of works over the last five decades
the downside for us is that the
algorithms that typically come out of
this work
are computationally inefficient in high
dimensions because they run in time
exponential in the dimensionality of the
data
and so that leads us to you know the
main topic of our interest today which
is
algorithmic robust statistics where our
goal is to design
efficient algorithms in high dimensions
to
robustly learn or robustly solve
learning problems
and our effort would be to get as good
an
error in the estimates we make as is
statistically permissible
okay so concretely i'm going to focus on
two models so let me quickly describe
these models to you
the first model of robust learning that
i will focus on
is the so-called strong contamination
model and it generalizes the original
model that peter hoover had proposed
more than five decades ago
and you know one you know simple
sentence to remember this model by
is simply that you know the input sample
that you see
is obtained by corrupting a small
constant let's say 10 percent
of the data in an arbitrary way okay
more precisely you imagine that there is
an original iid sample
generated from your favorite statistical
model let's say
n points in d dimensions but you do not
get to see those endpoints as inputs
instead you see a sample y the only
guarantee on which
is that y intersects x in one minus
epsilon fraction of the points
okay and now you know you could be
interested in estimating whatever
parameter
that interests you about the
distribution d
from the corrupted sample y this could
be something
as basic as estimating the mean of d but
could be more complicated like
estimating the covariance or estimating
you know regression or estimating
parameters of the mixture etc
notice that even basic tasks like
estimating the mean of the distribution
d
can get somewhat hairy in this model you
know if you simply use for example the
empirical mean of y
as the estimator for the mean of the
distribution d
then notice that even a single
corruption a single point being
corrupted
can throw you arbitrarily off in your
estimate okay
so even mean estimation is somewhat
challenging in this model
so that's the strong contamination model
if time permits at the end
i will also tell you a little bit about
the list decoding model
which again the tagline to remember it
by is that in this model
in contrast to the strong contamination
model you have
90 percent of the data corrupted that is
you know majority and overwhelming
majority of the data
is corrupted and only a small but fixed
constant fraction of the data
is pure or you know part of the original
sample
and you know because more than a
majority of the data
is completely corrupted in the setting
you cannot hope to recover
the unknown parameters you know uniquely
so the goal is a relaxed version here
you want to recover a small constant
size list of parameters
information theoretically the
permissible list size is at most one
over alpha so you know you want to go
somewhat close to it so you want to have
a small constant size list of
candidate parameters it could be mean
covariance just as previously
so that one of these candidate
parameters is close to the truth
okay now uh you know these models are so
natural that you might expect that there
must be tons and tons of work on it you
know going back 10 20 30 years but
somehow for whatever reason uh people
didn't actually think about this
you know these natural questions until
these two really nice works of li
rao and venpala and daikon nicolas kane
kamath lee moitra
stewart began this investigation by
focusing on the strong contamination
model
and since then and this you know work of
character steinhardt valiant that began
the work on this decoding model
there have been tons and tons of works
in this area by some estimates there
might be as much as
500 papers both theory and applied
you know that deal with robust learning
problems
that is not all of our interest today
today i am going to focus on the results
in this area
that use the sum of squares method that
you might have heard the name of but
i'll tell you a little bit more
later on today and this slide is here
to impress upon you that the story i'm
telling is legit as in
there is a good reason to study a
blueprint if there is one
behind you know algorithm design using
sum of squares for robot statistics
and the reason is that simply because
you can obtain many many results for
basic robust learning tasks using this
framework okay
so on this slide you can see that there
are results for basic tasks like
mean estimation or more generally
covariance and higher moment estimation
even for like you know simple tasks like
linear regression clustering spherical
mixtures non-spherical mixtures and very
recently
learning mixtures when they are not even
clusterable
um you know there is there is somewhat
somewhat less but still you know
reasonable amount of work in this
decodable model which is a harsher
noise model and you know the results are
known for problems like mean estimation
or regression or subspace clustering
and then there's this third line of work
on heavy tail estimation which doesn't
directly fit these two models that i
wrote on the previous slide
but it's kind of closely related and you
can ask me in questions later on how
actually that is so if you're interested
but the point of the slide as i said is
to tell you that in all the two relevant
models that i mentioned before
there is tons of work on basic
estimation tasks
in this robust learning setting using
the sum of squares method
okay the punch line that i will expand
on
more as the talk progresses of this line
of work
is that sum of squares yields the
algorithms for these problems
that work under the least restrictive
known
assumptions on the underlying
distribution okay and i'll both
demystify and tell you why
you know this actually happens later on
today
good so with that prologue now i can
tell you what my goal is i want to
describe this general blueprint
on how to design algorithms from the
previous slide
i'll tell you this key technical engine
that governs you know
how these algorithms actually succeed
and then state open questions about this
key technical engine
that can lead to improvement in all
known algorithms on
you know the previous slide okay now you
know
just like previous talks i'll have to
make compromises today and the
compromise i'll make today is that i
will not give you any proofs
unfortunately
all right let's proceed so as i said you
know i want to first tell you
the a general blueprint for designing
robust learning algorithms
and i'll start with the strong
contamination model okay
so here is the model written for your
benefit you know your input
is you know going to be a sample y which
intersects an unknown iid sample from
your favorite statistical model
in all but an epsilon fraction of the
points the remaining epsilon fraction of
the points are completely
arbitrary and adversarial outliers okay
and your goal is to you know estimate
whatever parameter of the distribution d
that you might be interested in
good so i want to tell you how you will
start
how you can start thinking about an sos
based algorithm for solving such a
genetic problem
you start by making uh well you know and
i'm going to you know draw a picture for
you because every talk
should have a picture so one
the first thing you'll do this is
basically you know step zero if you will
is you know you will make some
reasonable assumption on the
distribution d
and i'll think of this as enclosing
the input that you see inside a
reasonable class of distributions
okay now one important note about the
notation i'll use
i i you know associate to any finite set
x the distribution which is uniform
on the points in that set okay so i'll
interchangeably think of x as both a set
and the corresponding uniform
distribution on it
okay one nice way to think about y and x
is to note that y intersect x being
bigger than one minus epsilon n
is same as saying that the total
variation distance
between the uniform measures on x and y
is at most epsilon
for our purpose it won't really add that
much but our results actually will hold
more generally for you know total
variation close distributions
and i'll point this out you know when i
when i state it
anywho so the first step is going to be
to start from this sample
x and you know make some reasonable this
assumption on the distribution of x
okay this is what i'm going to call
enclosing x
you know inside some reasonable class of
distributions that's my
you know this x shaped object here good
now the y that you get is not going to
be
usually a point you know inside the set
the uniform distribution and y in other
words
will not satisfy the reasonableness
condition that you invented
it will naturally be outside of it but
the guarantee you have on y
is that it's at most epsilon far in
either hamming normalized hamming
distance
or total variation distance as i
described from
the true but unknown you know original
sample x
okay so given this prologue i can
immediately describe to you what a meta
algorithm that sum of squares implements
in this context looks like
okay here is what the algorithm does
it simply draws a ball of hamming
distance epsilon
or total variation distance epsilon
around y
and takes any member in the intersection
of this ball
with the class of reasonable
distributions that you have so defined
okay in other words find any x prime
that is epsilon close to y and is
reasonable
and then simply return the parameters of
x prime
that's it that's the meta algorithm okay
and now now for the meta analysis
the meta analysis proceeds by observing
that if x and y
are at most epsilon for and y and x
prime
is at most epsilon phi simply because
you found an x prime which is epsilon
close to y
then by triangle inequality x and x
prime must be at most
two times epsilon four okay again the
distance when you look at them as
point sets is just hamming distance and
when you think of them as distributions
is total variation distance
okay um and so okay so
what's the so the analysis you know
basically proves this one
super super neat you know and
the the and the and the statement says
uh you know this statement tries to
bound
the distance between parameters the
relevant parameters of
x and x prime in terms of the total
variation distance between them
okay now let me maybe pause and make one
important point here the bound you get
in this analysis would depend very
strongly
on the notion of reasonableness that you
have chosen in particular if you were to
choose some definition which is overly
general
and you know y itself somehow is allowed
to sit inside
this class of reasonable distributions
then you shouldn't expect
any bound on the distance between x and
x on the parameter distance between x
and x prime
okay and this will become clear once you
know i i give you one example of mean
estimation on the next slide
so the bounds that you get in this step
3a
would very strongly depend on what
definition of reasonableness you have
adopted okay
but whatever definition you choose you
will need to analyze
the parameter distance between two
distributions which are close in total
variation distance
and lie inside the class of your chosen
reasonable distributions
okay finally you know all the steps that
i told you so far
you know have nothing algorithmic going
on in them in fact they are completely
information theoretic
in order to make this whole blueprint
into an efficient algorithm
you need an efficient representation
of the class of reasonable distributions
you have chosen
okay now you know in our context this
representation would be
you know generated by sos certificates
but if you like right now you do not
know of them
so i implore you to think of them
precisely as you know some semi definite
representation
of the class of all reasonable
distributions so now this is just an
attempt to have an
efficient you know way to decide
membership in the class of reasonable
distributions if you will okay so we
just want this set to be somehow simple
okay that's the general blueprint of
both the algorithm and the analysis
in order to you know make this idea
clear let's take a very simple example
of mean estimation next
okay so here's the problem
you know this time you are interested in
estimating the parameter which is simply
the mean of the distribution d
and everything else is the same so y is
you know an epsilon corrupted sample of
x
and you are you know interested in
getting a good estimate of the mean of d
okay now we have to choose if you want
to implement the blueprint from the
previous slide
we have to choose you know some
assumption on d
or some class of reasonable
distributions to enclose
x by okay the simplest assumption i
would make
is that the variance of d is at most one
in every direction okay this is rather
natural because if you think about it
even in real life when you're trying to
you know use em you know
analyze the empirical mean and the
closeness or closeness of it to the
distributions mean
then you need some assumptions about
bounded variance to get reasonable
bounds
so let's think of our class of
reasonable distributions
as all distributions whose covariance
you know the max eigen value of
covariance is at most one or
equivalently the variance of
distribution d
in any direction is one okay
that's our class of reasonable
distributions now let's implement this
meta algorithm in this case you know
it's very simple
we simply try to find a distribution or
a set of points
x prime whose empirical covariance you
know is upper bounded in spectral norm
by one
and the observation y that we get to see
intersects with x prime in at least one
minus epsilon fraction of the points
okay and then you know as we discussed
in the previous slide we simply output
the mean of x prime
now let's see what the analysis
statement looks like
the analysis has to find a bound on the
l2 distance between mean of
x and x prime when you are guaranteed
that the total variation distance
between x and x prime is at most let's
say some 2 epsilon
so here is a claim which is actually not
so hard to prove but as i said i will
not give you any proofs today
this claim says that the l2 distance
between the mean of x and x prime
is at most o of square root of epsilon
where epsilon is the bound or 2 epsilon
is the bound
on total variation distance between x
and x prime or
you know more precisely the unit the
uniform distributions on x and x prime
okay um one thing before we go ahead is
important to observe
notice that this error bound has no
dependence on the dimension
of the problem so you know this error
bound is
is in euclidean you know this error is
in euclidean error
and the bound is completely independent
of the dimension
moreover for the class of reasonable
distributions we have chosen namely
bounded variance distribution
this bound is in fact tied up to
absolute constants
okay and so that's our analysis okay and
so nothing algorithmic has happened yet
but we've already derived an
interesting result that at least
information theoretically we can hope to
estimate the mean of a distribution
you know up to some of root epsilon
error as long as its variance in every
direction is upper bounded by one
um you know like in previous slide we
have to
attempt to find a reasonable an
efficient description of the class of
all
reasonable distributions i will not go
into too much detail about this right
here because i want to
do it in more generality in the next
slide but in this particular case
it follows actually very simply just by
noting that
you know you're interested in you know
the set of all x prime
where the covariance of x prime is you
know upper bounded by identity in the
learner ordering sense now this
description by itself is
not you know semi-definite in x prime
but you can massage it and make it into
one
okay that's all i want to say right now
but that's one concrete implementation
of the blueprint on the previous slide
okay but as i said
i want to you know refine this blueprint
and
try to and tell you how you can actually
get a stronger result
okay let's say that now you make
a stronger assumption on the
distribution d this time
you assume that so
let's maybe analyze or let's look at
this you know uh assumption
written inside this ball over here
carefully
before you move on to the stronger
assumption is it clear from the easier
case that the you know that that out
yeah is it clear that this algorithm is
equivalent to just removing points
that contribute you know a lot of
variants in in any direction
uh absolutely yes so you so yeah so so i
am thinking of
uh you know uh as algorithm i'm thinking
of algorithms that you know you will use
uh
you know this this particular blueprint
here but you're right
that the same observation actually
implies that you know you can filter out
points of
large length or large projection in some
direction
and you know you can get similar
guarantees with this filtering algorithm
that you're suggesting here
so you know simply just take a direction
of large
empirical variance in y and remove you
know uh
some um largest points in that direction
and that would actually also give you a
similar result
and that quantitatively gives you a
similar result
and the constant might be different but
yes overflow epsilon error would follow
good so moving on
we want to now make a stronger
assumption let's say that you know
we know that the distribution d that we
were given samples from
satisfied the stronger property if i
center
x as in subtract of the mean from x so x
bar is the mean subtracted quantity
then project it to any direction v then
the fourth moments of this 1d
distribution
can be controlled as an absolute
constant times the square of the second
moment
okay so we're just able to bound the
fourth moment in terms of the square of
the second moment
up to an absolute constant okay i'm
going to define this quantity or define
this property loosely as the property of
being
c sub gaussian okay i'll explain this
terminology in just a slide so bear with
me
okay but this is a different assumption
and in fact it's a stronger assumption
than the one we made
on the previous slide and you can try to
implement the same blueprint for this
stronger
assumption or you know a smaller class
of reasonable distributions
the algorithm blueprint remains exactly
the same try to find an x prime
which now satisfies this stronger
property
and intersects with y in one minus
epsilon fraction of the points
and then simply output the mean of x
prime okay
this time the analysis however improves
you can prove that if there are two
distributions
which are both c sub gaussian and
are at most let's say o of epsilon close
in total variation distance
then their means in l2 can only be
epsilon to the three quarters of a
which is by the way a smaller quantity
than root epsilon that we had on the
previous slide
okay both are dimensional independent
constants but the dependence on the
total variation distance is better in
this case
okay uh now you know
uh i want to now stress upon and so you
know i as i as i mentioned
to make this all algorithmic you need to
find some efficient representation
of you know the class of all reasonable
distributions
in this particular case c subgaussian
distributions
okay so let's investigate that further
because you know this
is the key technical engine i was
mentioning at the beginning of the talk
okay how can you find efficient
representations
of you know distributions which are
reasonable in this particular sense
so this is this property of certifiable
subgaussianity
and i'll explain the certifiable part
now i've only explained sub gaussianity
to you
i'll explain the certifiable part now so
here's the definition okay it was first
formalized in this work with david
stroider in 2018
a distribution d i'm going to call t
comma c
sub gaussian okay if this is
us if you look at this inequality here
is the same kind of inequality that we
were writing for t
equals 4 on the previous slide it says
that the
t moment of the centered distribution
d and any direction can be controlled
in terms of the t over 2 power of the
second moment of the distribution in the
same direction
and the constant you know depends on t
now
when it is sub gaussian it has to depend
like o of t to the t over 2
but i'm not going to be too concerned
with what exact the dependence is on t
for example if it is t to the t i'm also
okay with it okay
so this is the rather loose usage of the
word subgaussian but permit me to do it
now so far this is simply you know some
bounded moment property or subgaussian
moment property
the certifiable part comes in the
following sense
i want this particular inequality
to have a sum of squares proof let me
explain what that means okay
notice that both the left and right hand
sides of this inequality
do not depend on x bar or d as in you
know it's expected out
both left and right hand sides
inequality are simply
degree t polynomials in
the d dimensional vector v okay
so the left and right hand sides of this
inequality are simply degree t
polynomials in v
so this is a polynomial inequality in
variable v
okay so i say that this inequality
has a sum of squares certificate or
equivalently distribution d
is certifiably sub gaussian if
the right hand side of this inequality
minus the left-hand side of this
inequality
seen as a degree t polynomial is a sum
of squares polynomial
in v okay
that's a definition notice that this is
a stronger criteria than just
asking for this inequality to be true in
particular
if the difference of right and left hand
sides is a sum of squares polynomial
then certainly the inequality is true
but the other way around need not be
true in in general
asking for this bizarre algebraic
condition to hold
is you know at least a stronger in you
know requirement than what we actually
you know
uh than just this inequality the
subgaussianity inequality written above
okay so a priori you might be tempted to
think well this is first of all a
bizarre condition
and two you know if you had any
intuition about subgaussianity
then it may not actually hold when you
ask for the stronger condition because
we are asking for a very specific
representation
of this polynomial right so let me you
know la some of those spheres
here is an observation
if you look at gaussian distribution
then
in fact you know gaussian distribution
is rotationally invariant
and the left and right hand side is
inequality in you know the
the inequality is in fact satisfied with
equality where the precise function
is in fact this double factorial
function which grows roughly as t
to the t over 2 okay the point being
that since we have an equality the
difference of the
right hand and left hand side is simply
0 which is an interesting sum of squares
polynomial in v
okay so what we have simply established
by observing this
is that at the very least the gaussian
distribution
is certifiably subgaussian okay
good um here is a here are two more
easy observations the the second
observation
in this the number two observation here
is that this
this inequality i have here is affine
invariant
linear invariance is actually very easy
to see if i you know take any matrix a
and shift the random variable x by ax
then you know just by the way it's
written you can see that you know the
inequality will continue to hold even
after i shift the whole
you know random variable by a you can
also prove with some effort that it's
affine invariant but i won't go into it
and you know using this idea you can
actually prove it for affine
transforms of all you know t wise
uniform or t wise independent
distributions
this is also not very hard and you know
there's a relatively simple observations
so you know if you were a little bit
concerned about this inequality being
too you know too strict or too
restrictive at least you know
you can see that it holds for some
reasonable class of distributions
now you might be rather disappointed
that all that i have
on the slide here are basically you know
affine transforms of product
distributions
so you can ask well you know are there
some non-trivial non-product
distributions
for which we can prove this inequality
in a certifiable way
it turns out that it is true in this
work with jacob steinhardt
from 2018 we proved that if the
distribution d
satisfies a dimension independent
poincare inequality
i'll explain that what that is in a
second then
in fact this fact hold the search like
then d
is certified with sub gaussian in other
words the difference of right and left
hand sides can
indeed be written as a sum of squares
polynomial
in v okay now uh some of you might
already know of poincare inequality
here is what it means it simply is you
know an example of a lipschitz
concentration inequality
you know these are inequalities that say
that lipschitz functions
on these distributions you know enjoy
some dimension independent concentration
so if you look at you know this
inequality written in red at you know
on the slide it says that the variance
of any function
can be bounded in terms of expectation
of the squared l2 norm of gradient of f
so if gradient of f is let's say bounded
that's what we may we might want to mean
by lipidness of f
then this says that the variance of any
left function is a constant
okay now this is some rather awkward
condition if you not heard about it
but you know here is a class of
distributions that you might
actually have heard about that satisfy
this inequality and therefore
immediately are rendered
certifiably subgaussian so all strongly
lock concave distributions
satisfy this property so what's a strong
lock and gap distribution if you haven't
seen it
it's basically you know the fact it's
condition under which if you take
log of the density function then it's a
strongly concave function
okay that's that's what that's all it
means and so gaussians of course are an
example there are but
you know you know if you but there are
more general examples in particular you
know uniform distributions on
smooth convex bodies satisfy this
property
okay good that actually brings me to the
first open question that i promised at
the beginning of the talk
which is simply to find more general
distribution classes
that satisfy this property of
certifiable subgaussianity
okay now one class that might be
motivated from our discussion on the
previous slide
is simply you know the class of all log
concave distributions not strongly like
concave but all lock concave
now if you followed all this recent
excitement about the kls cooling
conjecture
then you probably know that this
conjecture implies
that all lock concave distributions
satisfy poincare inequality with a
dimension independent constant
but you know the inequality that we want
as a consequence from it
should rather have a standalone and
perhaps a simple proof i just don't know
of one right now
okay i want to mention that you know
there is this very recent exciting
progress in this manuscript of chen
that seems to you know get a non-trivial
upper bound on the poincare constant of
you know low concave distributions
it's still not a dimension independent
constant but you know as i'll mention
the next slide it already implies
non-trivial improvements to many
algorithms in that list
of robust learning algorithms i showed
you earlier so in particular
in this is basically the list of
problems i showed you earlier
i have marked all the problems that rely
only on the property of certifiable
subgaussianity
which means that if you manage to show
more general distributions or
certificates of gaussian
you immediately upgrade all these
results
okay and this results in particular
include regression and moment estimation
and clustering etc okay by the way you
know i'm going to pause and say that
this is the most exciting part of
research in sum of squares based
algorithms for me
that somehow you know you prove a result
and then you can simply
you know upgrade a certain technical
part and
you know make the result in a black box
way hold for a more general family of
distributions
good so that's the motivation for the
open question one
let me now move on and switch gears and
tell you a little bit
about list decodable learning algorithms
okay
so this is the second model i mentioned
earlier
this is the model of learning where 90
of the sample that you see could
actually be completely corrupted
and only 10 percent could actually
contain clean samples
okay so i would be
actually much less understandable or at
least you know i would be
you know i you know i would be a little
bit quick with the description of
this both the model um and you know the
example
because i want to get to this property
that would upgrade all the results and
you know state the open question
so i'll somehow keep my discussion uh
centered
you know in a way that you know allows
me to get to this property quickly
okay but let me you know tell you what
this blueprint looks like it looks very
similar to what we saw earlier
we again want to choose some notion of
reasonable distributions
and enclose the original sample that we
never got to see
inside this class of distributions the
y that we get to see this time is you
know not
epsilon but some 1 minus alpha away in
total variation distance remember 1
minus alpha could be a number like 0.9
okay so this time you
you know can't just hope to find one
element
one reasonable distribution which is one
minus alpha close to y
and you know somehow hope to infer that
that element would be close to x2
because triangle inequality gives you
nothing here
but it turns out that with some effort
you can show that if you find some
well separated one over alpha different
members
of this you know intersection between
one minus alpha ball around y
and the reasonable distributions then
one of them would be roughly 1 minus
alpha close in total variation distance
to x okay
whichever way you do it you can with
some generic tricks arrive at an
x1 prime which is one minus alpha
separated
at most one minus alpha separated from
the true original sample
x okay and now you simply output
uh you know the parameters of x prime
instead or x one prime instead
okay so it's very similar to the
previous blueprint the only change is
that you have to hunt for like a larger
list in order to guarantee that there is
something
close to the unknown x okay
good the analysis is you know also very
similar but this time we have to prove a
result about parameter distance
when the bound on the total variation
distance between the two reasonable
distributions we have
is rather weak it's like only 0.9
instead of 0.1
from the previous slides okay and of
course to make it all efficient we have
to find efficient representations
or you know succinct representations of
the class of reasonable distributions
that we are working with
okay so let me you know briefly tell you
one problem and you know in fact the
first uh
you know non-trivial problem that was
resolved you know in this um
actually second non-trivial problem that
was resolved in this line of work which
is this joint work with adam
here and swish with karmalker so
and you know as usual i want to focus on
you know uh this this this
technical engine of finding efficient
representations of you know reasonable
class of distributions so
here is the problem it's the problem of
list decodable
uh regression and here is what that
means in simple terms okay
so my x is going to be this time labeled
samples or labeled data
and you know i have d dimensional points
and the labels
are just evaluations of some linear
function
with coefficient vector l star on each
of the data points
okay so you know so this is basically a
sample a data sample on r
to the d cross r okay if you're if
you're familiar with regression
then notice that this is regression
without any error okay so this is
basically simply linear equations
okay that's the original sample now
why you know just like in the previous
slide is going to be some
enlargement of x where i've added one
minus
alpha fraction of completely arbitrary
outliers
okay and my goal is to output a o of 1
or alpha size list of parameters
l 1 through l k such that at least one
of the lis is close to l star
okay so that's that's my goal in this
list decodable regression problem
now we will implement this outline and
the implementation is rather
natural so i will actually not discuss
it in detail
instead simply focus on this you know
analysis step
to motivate this discussion of what
reasonable distribution should be
okay so whatever class of reasonable
distributions we choose
the key thing it influences is the
following guarantee
we have to somehow come up with a
parameter distance bound
meaning you know bound between you know
bound on the l2 distance between vectors
l and l star when the only guarantee we
have is that
l solves the equations in x prime
l star solves the equation in x x and x
prime are both
you know chosen from some reasonable
distributions
and the total variation distance between
x and x prime
is at most one minus alpha now in our
present context
this this this whole you know
this this this whole mouthful of a
sentence that i spoke
means something very simple it means the
following suppose you have two
sets of linear equations x and x prime
okay
and they agree on an alpha fraction of
the equations as in their right hand
side
so you know like um the left hand sides
or the x
i's for alpha fraction of the equations
are exactly the same in x and x sub
prime
and so are the right hand sides so you
know basically alpha fraction of the
equations are shared between x and x
prime the remaining one minus alpha
fraction are arbitrary and different
okay now we haven't yet invented
reasonable class of distributions we are
going towards it okay
we are trying to understand you know
what notion of reasonableness should we
use
so that whenever x and x prime share
alpha fraction of the equations
then their solution should be close okay
so here is you know a simple thought
experiment suppose
you know l some different vector happens
to be a solution to x prime
then notice that in for every x which is
you know the coefficient vector of an
equation in the intersection of x and x
prime
if i evaluate you know the equation
at the uh at the vector
l minus l star because both lx and
l star x are equal to the right hand
sides their difference must be zero
okay so in other words i have found a
vector
l minus l star so that if i you know
take inner product of this vector
with every point in the intersection of
you know x and x prime
then i get zero okay so we would like to
say that the only way this can happen
is if l equals l star if i have some
condition on the distribution
of the equations that ensures that you
know the only way this can happen is
that l is equal to l star
then i would know that you know then i
would have the right
reasonableness condition in this context
so
that is actually rather easy if we
actually have come up with this thought
experiment already
and you know if you heard of this
condition it simply says that
the only way that a projection in some
direction of a distribution can be zero
more than alpha fraction of the times
is when the vector v itself is zero in
other words there is no non-zero vector
such that when i project the
distribution to direction v i get
zero alpha or more than alpha fraction
of the times
okay now when you state
anti-concentration in more generality
you actually allow not just
zero the projection being zero but
projection being small etc
you know i want to stick to the setting
which is directly relevant so i'm
setting it this way here
okay now if you know you want to get
algorithms out of it
you have to get reasonable descriptions
of distributions which are you know
which satisfy this anti-concentration
property i wrote on the previous slide
and so you need to invent a certifiable
notion of anti-concentration
which is there before you you know on
the slide now you know this was
formalized in two works which
independently discovered an algorithm
for less decodable regression
i'm actually presenting a more general
formulation and both this works it you
know this formulation
you know like both the proofs in the
formulation used in
both these papers can be seen as a
special case of this particular
formulation
but i think for further investigation
this is probably the right one so that's
why i'm saying it here
so i'm going to call a distribution
which you can think of as simply a
finitely supported distribution on n
sample x as t of delta certifiably
anti-concentrated
if there is a degree t sum of squares
proof
in variables w comma v of the following
implication so on the left hand side
just to parse it out
says that you know wi square is wi
meaning wis are
either 0 or 1 valued x
is a collection of n points x 1 through
x and in d dimensions
the second condition says that whenever
w i is 1 x
i dot v should be zero so w i you can
think of as
indicator of the the the the points in x
at which x i dot v is zero and you know
the third condition simply says that v
should be nonzero vector and we just
force it by saying that v is a unit
vector okay
so basically the three conditions on the
left hand side of this
implication say that you know i'm trying
to look for
a set of points such that when i project
it to a non-zero direction v
i get 0 okay and the implication the
right hand side says
that if i do find such a v and w's then
you know the number of points i would
have found is at most delta
so this is just an encoding of the
statement in you know in terms of
polynomial inequalities that we saw
earlier
which says that you know this
distribution x
cannot project to zero in any direction
v more than delta fraction of the times
okay now i haven't told you what a sum
of squares proof is
i gave you an example very restricted
example in the previous
setting of certifiable sub gaussianity
but it simply means that if i subtract
the rh
left hand side from the right hand side
then it is a sum of squares polynomial
plus some polynomial multiple of you
know the polynomials that appear on the
left hand side
and let me not go into detail but you
know there is a natural notion that
generalizes the one that we saw earlier
now this notion is much less understood
than
certifiable subgaussianity we actually
only have two
examples that these two works proved are
certifiably anti-concentrated
and they are basically you know well
actually this really one example to be
honest
simply gaussians and you know just you
know close relatives of gaussians
actually satisfy
this property we do not have you know a
very good understanding of this property
yet
okay so which brings me to my second set
of open questions
um uh maybe focus on open question two
first which is you know can you extend
these proofs of certifiable
anti-concentration to more general
distributions
and in particular can you extend into
isotropic concave distributions
i do not know of it and two can you
improve the degree of certifiable
anti-concentration
for simply gaussians so right now you
know the result i showed you in the
previous slide
shows that you know the degree of the
proof is one over delta square and
roughly this translates into the
exponent of the running time of
algorithms that depend on this
in this notion so if you improve these
bounds you would also improve the
running time of the algorithms
all right so that's actually all i want
to tell you uh today
this is you know the list of problems i
showed you in the beginning of
this talk and you know the right hand
side
shows you which conditions on the
distributions
are enough to make those results go
through so if you look at you know
the list decodable learning algorithms
over here
they actually will improve already if
you you know solve the second set of
open problems or improve or make any
progress towards them
good so i want to end by simply uh you
know
noting two simple conclusions so at the
beginning of
the talk i said that you know one
property of sum of squares based
algorithms
is that they give you um robust learning
algorithms
under the least restrictive assumptions
and perhaps going through the talk tells
you how that comes about you know we
neatly
identify this algorithmically relevant
property of the distribution
this condition of reasonableness and
then simply investigate for
what most general class of distributions
does that reasonableness hold okay
and so one uh one one great upshot of
such
results is that you can upgrade several
algorithms
simultaneously if you simply improve the
understanding of this technical
algorithmically relevant property
now you know it's a fit for me to also
point out what's the downside of
designing algorithms using sos
and one you know one immediate one is
simply that you know
uh the notion of efficiency of these
algorithms is rather coarse
and which is simply just polynomial time
and usually you can't design
hyper-efficient algorithms using this
kind of a method
sometimes you can although you know
speed up algorithms based on sos so
there is some
upshot to even that all right so that's
all i want to say
thank you uh so much for listening and
you know if you want to learn more
there is this monograph that we wrote on
sum of squares method especially focused
on learning
problems and especially focus on
identifying such you know
simple properties of distributions that
make these algorithms work
uh also there is a class i'm teaching
right now which uh
the notes of which i intend to make
public in a month or so so there'll be
more material out on this
topic soon all right that's all thanks
okay great um any questions for pravesh
i have a question for you so the you
know some of the problems that you
mentioned on the
prior slide
you know like list list equitable
subspace recovery implies less decodable
regression
yes um what's the most
kind of expressive problem that would
sort of imply solutions
to all of them that's still open
uh wait you mean a problem or a property
problem
problem uh uh
maybe i i'm still i guess i'm not
totally so for example you know this
decodable covariance estimation
or ah i see what what's the problem that
is oh i see okay so i i
i focus this stuff on what's moving the
most expressive problem that you could
hope to solve that would sort of
you know unify all of these results yes
yes uh absolutely so you have
that's a really good point i think you
are giving me kind of a plug to plug in
this
also one more very nice open question so
what adam is mentioning is that there is
a natural generalization of these two
problems
at the bottom of the slide list
decodable regression and list decodable
subspace clustering
which is this problem of this decodable
covariance estimation
here is the simple problem alpha
fraction of the points that you see
are iid samples from an unknown gaussian
with an unknown mean and unknown
covariance okay
the rest of the one minus alpha fraction
of the points are completely adversarial
outliers
you want to find a list of parameters of
one over alpha size list of parameters
parameters mean
meaning mean and covariances such that
one of the pairs of parameters describes
the gaussian
which is close in total variation
distance to the unknown gaussian so you
basically want to
you know recover good estimates of the
parameters of the unknown gaussian
that gave you the alpha fraction of the
points
we do not know any algorithm for this
problem you can think of both regression
and subspace clustering as
special cases of this problem you know
which you know imposes some special
structure on both mean and covariances
of a general problem we do not know of a
solution and actually you know it will
unify a lot of
results on this slide not just list
recordable ones but it would also imply
results for this clustering problems
over here so yes
as adam said this is kind of a you know
grand unified problem
you know at least for the purpose of
problems on this slide
also open
okay well thanks pravesh uh for that
whirlwind tour
that was fun and we'll start again
tomorrow morning if you're if uh neural
networks and deep learning is
of interest to you please tune in and
we'll see you then
thanks thank you